Hey, everybody.
Thank you for allowing us to once again
hold you pod-hostage for another-
Hostage.
Rendition of Roll On.
Wherein my cogitative, neighborly,
and rather magnanimous sidecar, hypebeast,
Mr. Adam Skolnick.
And I indulge you with troll repartee, raillery,
shrewd observations on concept issues
and matters of importance,
both great and probably not so much.
Yes, usually.
Right?
Yes.
We also do
a wee bit of show and tell, and of course,
answer some of your listener questions from our voicemail.
You can leave us a message at 424-235-4626.
So lean back or lean in, smash that subscribe button,
hit the notification's bell wherever that is,
click the like, leave your comments
in the comment section below,
as all those YouTubers are fond of saying.
And let's get into it, Adam, how you doing?
Doing great, man, I'm feeling good.
I've enjoyed the rain a little bit.
Got in the water yesterday.
It rained pretty hard.
Rained this morning-
Last night.
Pretty hard last night.
You don't
wanna be getting in the water
right after a rainstorm.
No.
We snuck one in yesterday.
It was nice and crisp, 55 degree Fahrenheit.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
How thick is your wetsuit?
Your website, your wetsuit.
My website's so thick.
I have a few different ones,
but the one I used yesterday is like a triathlon suit.
So it's kind of piecemeal,
so there's five millimeter in the chest,
four in the thighs, and then it's like .5 in the shoulders,
and you know, just different places-
So you're not wearing your swimrun wetsuit
for your adventures around the Point.
No, but then when you do a few dives, after awhile,
like the area where it's .5 starts to,
like you feel the cold there first,
and it just starts to radiate down, but it's fun.
I wear some weights, so the swim out and back
against the current with weights is kind of-
Right at the end of Zuma there,
where you go around the Point.
The Point.
Yeah, we started different places.
Yesterday, we walked down to the last
lifeguard tower and launch from there
and then went out and back, I went out and back.
My friends usually go around the Point,
but for me, I have the family on the beach,
so I try to, it means I don't get to see Big Dume,
but if I can grab an hour at the reef, that's like-
Also, you're more likely to steer clear
of predatory marine life that way.
I don't know if that's true.
Going around that Point is dicey.
When I tell people that I swam around that Point with you,
they look at me like I'm a crazy person.
We've talked about this before.
Right, but like where, even the pinnacles themselves
have so much life that anything that could get you
around the Point can get you at the pinnacles.
'Cause that's where the, like the main reef structure is.
(laughs) That's not making me feel better
about my next outing with you.
But
at this moment though,
it's like the beginning of the whale migration.
I mean, it started a few weeks ago,
but it's becoming more and more every day.
There's more whales coming through.
So if you can go, so an out and back,
you have a better chance of seeing them,
'cause you often see them off the beach
where the waves are more often
than where the pinnacles are, so-
What about the sharks, though?
How are the sharks impacted by the whale migration?
There is a shark season.
And you start to notice it when the sea lions
wash up on the beach with bites taken out of them.
But-
Also a confidence booster
when you're putting on the wetsuit.
Yes, but I think, I have to look at it,
but I think that the shark season is not, is coming up.
I think the main shark season is like in May, June.
It doesn't really dovetail, as far as I know,
in terms of the breeding.
'Cause what's happening is,
just not too far offshore in Santa Monica Bay,
I mean, Sunset where the surf break is,
like a half mile out there,
that's a shark nursery, as far as I understand it.
And there has been more juvenile whites this season
than they've seen in a long, long time.
At least that was what the reporting was,
excuse me, last season.
So I'd have to look.
Offhand, I forget when the breeding season is,
but that's the pupping season.
'Cause they're live birth.
They're like one of the fish
that actually gives live births.
Right.
Yeah.
I haven't heard of any attacks in recent memory, though.
No, we don't have a great history of like fatal attacks.
We have had some bites and stuff.
Usually, it's, again, it's connected to a swimmer
swimming under the pier and the fishermen
had a juvenile white on the line
and it was angry and it hit the swimmer.
That was the most recent one.
What is the conventional wisdom about how long
you should wait after a big rain to go in the ocean?
'Cause there's so much toxic runoff.
So I know that you're not supposed
to do it for a couple days.
Three days.
Three days?
72 hours is what they usually do, yeah.
If it's rained a bunch in a row,
probably can get away with two days,
'cause it's not like the first coat
of that slick grime from the streets.
'Cause what happens is all that gets into the storm drains.
The storm drains end up in the ocean,
and that's the main reason.
So it's like the toxins
and the fertilizers and things like that.
Have you ever gotten sick because you got in
too early after-
I have not, I have not.
I've been lucky, but I usually do abide by the 72 hours.
I don't mess around.
Surfers are less likely to abide,
because they have to surf when the waves are there.
But they're not under water the same way.
So like, they're mostly above water.
They're not getting a lot of-
But what would be
the symptoms?
Like what would you catch?
I think ear infections would be the first thing.
Ear infections, could be sinus infection.
Diarrhea, dysentery.
It could be.
If you like to drink seawater.
Yeah, I just remember when I was,
I've probably told this story before,
but it's been a really long time if I have.
When I was living in New York City, right after college,
like '89, '90, '91, my roommate, Matt Nats,
who was a teammate of mine on the Stanford swim team
decided that he wanted to do the swim
around Manhattan that they hold every year.
At that point in time,
I was not interested in endurance sports,
so I opted out of that.
In fact, he wanted me to crew for him
and I had a family vacation in Michigan,
so I missed the whole thing.
But I remember when he was training for that
and getting ready for it,
they send you like a binder full of information
that includes all the shots you have to get before,
'cause you're literally swimming in the Harlem River.
You're going all the way around Manhattan.
And he had to get all these shots.
And then he told me that,
especially up in the northern points,
he would just run into garbage
like constantly as he was swimming.
And then he got a terrible urine infection afterwards
that he claimed had nothing to do with the swim.
But I can't imagine it didn't.
And I also remember that near,
sorta near the George Washington Bridge is this,
I don't know if it's still there
or if this is still a thing,
but there was this giant like suck hole.
Like there was something under the water that was like
basically creating a vacuum effect in this whirlpool.
And you had to steer very clear of that
or suffer the consequences
of getting sucked down.
Get suck down
into the black hole in the,
is it the, was that the East River
or the Hudson?
No, no,
in the Hudson, in the Hudson.
I think like a little bit south
of the George Washington Bridge, if memory serves me.
I could be wrong about that.
Yeah, that's the East River
to Harlem River to Hudson, right?
Isn't that the route or something like that?
You start down near Wall Street.
And I think you go up the East River first
and you come down the Hudson.
And he got second place.
I think he, I think at the time, it was probably '90 or '91,
he broke the men's record, but he got beat
by a 15-year-old Australian girl who was like this,
the queen, whose name escapes me,
But she was like the queen of open-water swimming.
Well, I mean, that was the triple crown, right,
so for many years-
And his crew was comprised
of like my hungover buddies.
Whoever he could find.
Yeah. (laughs)
Yeah, I need you to just hand me water every 30 minutes.
Right, who had no idea what they were in for.
And now I feel, I have tremendous regret
that I wasn't there for him to support her in that way.
But anyway, I don't know how we got off on that tangent.
Open-water swimming.
Yeah, speaking of the rains.
Yep.
I,
in anticipation of it raining last night,
I had to go and get a new tent, 'cause,
which is something I have to do like every six months
'cause the sun-
Really?
Beats down on my cheap tent,
and it becomes like tissue paper and it frays.
So there were all these holes in mine.
Oh my goodness.
it was like raining
in there, it was getting wet, and-
You slept through the rain?
Well, there were portions of it
where like water started to pool
and I was just too busy or lazy to go replace the tent.
So, you know, I had like, the bottom of my sheets
would be wet when I wake up in the morning,
and I was like, I gotta fix this.
So I went and got a new tent
and I was kind of taking everything out
and setting it up and putting everything in.
And I realized some stuff has mold in it.
Like this is not good.
So the thought occurred to me,
since I am sleeping in a tent basically every night,
like, why am I spending four, $500
on a new tent every six months?
I should get like a proper outdoor like canvas glamping tent
that could stand the test of time.
So I've been researching.
Like I could just get a huge tent
and like create a whole room.
So you're going from-
So now I'm excited
about this.
You're going from REI
to Vegas Cabana?
Something like that, yeah.
So I'm looking into like some cool tent designs.
If there's any canvas, high-end glamping canvas tent
manufacturers out there that wanna talk to me,
I'd love to hear from them.
Because, yeah, these tents just get shredded,
like they're just the sun beats down on them.
And then literally they just rip.
But wouldn't canvas also kind of take a beating up there?
Or not really?
Well, I would imagine,
but they're gonna last a couple of years.
Yeah, you get like a year-
Compared to six months.
Up there.
Yeah, we have a teepee.
But it's way down and far away from the house.
I don't know, so anyway, just,
that's what I'm thinking about.
Teepee could be cool.
A glamping tent, Adam.
Imagine-
Wanna glamp on the roof?
Yeah, so we're sort of constructing
this new little section of our home,
like on the side where,
which is where my container office is
and where I have this tent and we just got a cold plunge.
We're gonna talk about that in a little bit.
I saw that post.
I guess we could just talk
about it, we could just talk about it right now.
These guys, Michael Garrett and Ryan Duey,
who are out of Sacramento,
have this new company called thecoldplunge.com.
And they reached out to me
and just wanted to gift me a cold plunge,
which is one of the side benefits
of hosting a podcast, I suppose.
They create these next level cold baths
that are really beautiful,
like these beautiful tubs that have a filtration system
and a temperature gauge on them.
So you can just set the temperature
and it has a cover on it,
and it's always good to go.
So you don't have to worry about buying tons of ice
or trying to jerry-rig a top door freezer
so that you don't electrocute yourself,
which is what a lot of people do.
Which that's what I was thinking of doing.
'Cause I've done cold plunging before,
but never consistently,
'cause I don't have it at my house
and I'm not gonna be just going to the store
and buying bags and bags of ice all the time.
Most people like take one of those freezers,
the top drawer freezers.
The top drawer freezers,
yeah, and you have to customize them.
And I think you have to put like a lining.
It's like a, it's a little bit more of an elaborate process
than you might suspect rather than just
filling it with water and getting into it,
because it's not built for that.
But these guys just created like a standalone
situation that is very aesthetically cool.
And it works really well and doesn't require
like almost any maintenance whatsoever.
It must be so clean.
I think you just have to put,
they were telling me you just have to put,
I can't remember how much,
like a quart or two of hydrogen peroxide in it
every two weeks or something like that.
But it's filtering the water all the time.
So it's always filled with water?
Yeah, no, it's always filled with water,
and it's filtering the water all the time.
And then it has a temp gauge on it
so you can set the temp wherever you want it.
It will go down to 39 degrees.
And I hate cold water so much.
Like this is part of why I'm doing this
is because I have such an aversion to this.
Then I started it out at the wimpy temperature of like 58.
And I've been going down two degrees every day.
So I'm down to like today will be 48.
Which is a pretty good place.
That's great.
And I'm diggin' it.
It's been really great.
How long are you in there for?
So I do three rounds of four minutes,
and we also have an outdoor tub right next to it
so I fill that with hot water.
I eventually wanna get a barrel sauna,
like a proper sauna, we don't have that now.
But until that point, just alternating
between getting in the cold plunge
and then getting into the hot tub
and then doing three rounds of that.
I love it.
Four minutes each,
which has been great.
And it's so refreshing.
It is addictive, you hear that?
And it's not that it gets easier.
There's always that like,
I definitely don't wanna get in this freezing cold tub,
but I've gotten better at it.
And it's really a great kind of meditative practice,
because it forces you to be present.
Like you can't be thinking about anything else
except your breath.
The brain gets wiped.
Your brain is wiped.
So I wanted to thank those guys publicly,
Michael and Ryan.
If you wanna learn more,
you can go to thecoldplunge.com.
It is an expensive item.
And it was just so gracious of them to gift it to me.
And this is not a sponsored thing.
They didn't ask me to do anything.
But I just wanted to acknowledge them and let them know
that I appreciate it and that I'm putting it to use.
So that's been really fun.
What's that been doing physically for you?
I definitely sleep better.
Sleep's like my whole thing.
I'm always trying to optimize that.
So I've noticed that it's not that,
I don't have problems falling asleep,
but like around the middle of the night,
I'll often wake up and I found
that I'm sleeping more soundly throughout the night
and in a deeper state, according to my WHOOP, which is good.
It also has, you know, because it's so anti-inflammatory,
it's really been helping my back.
Really?
So when I'm,
like in the hours after doing it,
like my back feels better than it's felt in a long time.
So that's another initial, I mean,
I've only been doing this
for five days or something like that, but-
But you're already feeling-
I'm making it a daily
practice and I can definitely feel the difference.
And it's also a mood enhancer.
Like, you know when you kind of
in the middle of the afternoon,
you're a little, you've worked and not,
you're kind of burned out, you're a little bit tired.
If you do it mid-day, it's sort of like taking a power nap.
Like you just feel completely fresh again.
So that's been cool too.
It is cool, I love it.
So you do it in the morning, and then also, sometimes-
Well, it's just been based on my schedule.
Like yesterday, I did it after a long bike ride.
Doing it in the morning is great,
but I did it in the afternoon the other day.
I haven't had a consistent,
like I do it at this time every day,
kind of catch-as-catch-can, but I'm diggin' it.
It's been fun.
You'll have to come over and check it out.
I gotta do it, man, I love that thing.
Kevin Roose went up on the podcast.
That was super fun.
I felt like I was cheating on you a little bit.
(laughs) You're not at all.
Fellow New York Times writer.
He's a tenured professor over there.
He is.
He's an elder statesman.
I'm an associate.
He's higher up in the New York Times pecking order.
I'm not on the pecking order.
But it was really fun.
Actually, there were moments during that podcast
where I felt like it would have been good
to have you also on the mic.
So he's got an open invite to come on the show
next time he finds himself in LA.
So maybe if and when that happens,
we'll do it as a threesome.
Perfect.
But that was really cool.
Since we talk about his work so often on the show,
we'd been such champions of Rabbit Hole,
it was really fun and cool to talk to him.
I should also mention that Alex Honnold dropped by.
I've heard of him.
Late last week.
For those that don't know he is,
he climbed a very steep-
Quite steep.
Wall in Yosemite without any ropes.
They made a movie about it that won an Oscar.
And that was really cool.
He's been on the show before, long-time listeners know.
But it was cool to have him back on.
He's got this podcast that he's starting
called Climbing Gold,
that's about the history of climbing
and also about the upcoming introduction
of climbing into the Olympics.
So we talked about that.
But what was a couple of cool things about that experience,
he brought the van.
So the van was here at the studio.
He's still driving.
Which is amazing.
And it's got the little, the little finger grips
inside the door that he does his workouts on.
And you know, he was doing like two finger pull-ups
with one arm and stuff like that,
which was crazy to see.
And that interview was cool.
It was a little bit different from,
I think most interviews he has done of late,
because it's not about "Free Solo,"
It was more about kind of what he's up to now,
how do you move forward from something like that?
He recently spent a month in Guiana for a Nat Geo project.
So we talked a lot about the environment,
all the work that he's doing with his foundation,
the Honnold Foundation, solar energy, renewables.
And that episode is gonna go up, I believe March 29th.
So everybody has that to look forward to.
That's very cool.
I can't believe, I'm really surprised
he's still driving around that.
I shouldn't be, based on-
I think it is his second one, though.
At some point he upgraded it.
It looked, it didn't look new.
It looked like, he was stay,
apparently, he was gonna sleep in it.
I'm sure he did.
Yeah, so.
Anyway-
He parked it here,
hopped a flight to Guiana, came back here.
No, he lives in Vegas, so he drove here.
And then he had some other press stuff.
But his plan was to just, he was gonna see some friends,
and I'm sure, he told me he was just
gonna sleep in the back of the truck.
You never know.
Of course.
It's comfortable for him.
Should we recap the Goggins challenge?
All right.
It's been a week.
You've had time to reflect on the profundity
of this endurance feat that you accomplished.
How you feeling?
You know, I feel good.
Like my body feels totally fine.
I'm, it was fun to do.
It was, I mean,
I'm very appreciative of, you came out to visit,
I had other friends paced me, you paced me on your bicycle.
Other people paced, running.
I was getting messages galore from listeners
and their interests, encouragement was just like,
I didn't expect it.
And so it was really cool.
It was cool to be a part of.
I think early on after the first run,
the first run, I was kind of too keyed up,
and so eight o'clock hits and my legs have kind of,
are heavy in lactic acid on that very first run.
And I'm thinking to myself, that's okay,
'cause after this first run, I can take care of my body,
hydrate up, and then that'll be over.
And then, 'cause you're gonna get tired eventually,
so it's fine if it happens early on,
because the point is to run when you're tired.
So that first run, I was a little bit
not feeling that great, but pushed through,
and then from then on,
it just was kind of like a clockwork thing.
And yeah, I was able to get through each phase,
and Jason Camiolo.
Who's right behind me right now.
Who's right behind you.
He did it as well.
So you guys were, I know you guys were on the blower
with each other throughout the whole thing.
Yeah, messaging after every single one.
And I'd say like the second run,
I stayed up till midnight the first day.
Well, let's take a second and just,
if somebody is brand new
and they don't know what we're talking about,
the Goggins challenge is this challenge
that David Goggins proposed as kind of a crowdfunding,
not crowdfunding, but a participatory challenge
where you run four miles
every four hours for 48 hours straight.
It starts on a Friday night at eight o'clock, right?
And you go through late Sunday afternoon basically.
And so like the first run kind of,
I was a little keyed up in my calf,
my left calf was tightening up a little bit,
but that was fine.
I had a bit of an adrenaline crash after,
and I didn't wanna sleep before the first midnight.
I wanted to stretch and be ready.
And so I didn't, slept, the second run was a lot better,
slept a little bit after.
And then it was like, you know,
the 4:00 a.m. run, which was not very fast.
(laughs) I was running past people who sleep in their vans.
How much did you sleep before that run?
Probably two and a half, three hours.
That's pretty good.
That was probably
the longest sleep of the entire situation.
And then the fourth run, found a rhythm again.
And I was listening to earbuds for the first time,
that was 8:00 a.m. on Saturday.
And I found that it kind of took away from the experience.
Like I was, I thought I would
get through all of Bravy or something,
or like the whole, I was just gonna listen to books,
but I found that it just wasn't working for me.
Like I'd rather have the quiet.
And so I stopped doing that.
April ran two of the segments with me and she,
usually I push the pram,
but she was pushing the stroller the whole time.
So she did, I think I pushed it
for maybe half a mile at one point,
but she did 16 of the miles.
So she was with me and she rides.
And the fastest of the weekend was that six run,
the 20 to 24 miles.
And then all of a sudden,
people started calling me wanting to pace me.
My buddy, Adam Dole calls me.
Adam, early podcast guest.
Early podcast guest.
And shout out Adam Dole.
And he called me like, hey, do you want,
or texted me, do you want a pacer?
It's okay if you say no.
And I'm like, sure, at that point, I'll take any help.
And so he came in.
Another friend, Reece Pacheco who runs WSL PURE,
the environmental organization, he came in for noon.
And for the last day, Adam was at 8:00 p.m.,
then he came back for 4:00 a.m.
I mean, just incredible.
Wow, that's cool.
And yeah, and so through it all,
I didn't sleep much the second day.
I slept after the 8:00 p.m. to midnight,
and that was this craziest time,
because I set my alarm for 11:30 instead of 23:30.
And so then I slept through the midnight,
and I woke up just like in a start
like drenched in sweat at 12:20 a.m.
And I'm like fuck.
Disqualified.
And I had to like race to get my shit,
'cause at that point, I knew Adam was coming at four,
so there was pushing the 4:00 a.m. run.
So at that point, that's all off.
So I just ran out the door.
And so then, I stopped kind of,
like my legs started tightening up.
My knees started to hurt a little bit,
but for the most part, my body held up really well.
And you know, it was just a great experience.
Like I have to say, it's the, it's my,
the greatest athletic feat I think
of my lifetime that I've ever done.
That's cool.
And I didn't go into it
thinking that was gonna be the case,
but looking back, I have to say,
I don't think there's anything close,
maybe, I climbed Kilimanjaro, but that's,
I think less people have done this than have climbed Kili.
How would you compare those two?
I mean, it's apples and oranges, but-
This is way more demanding.
If you're in shape, Kili is not a killer.
It's a couple, there's difficult moments
and you're going into altitude, so altitude is a game.
Anybody could suffer from altitude at any time.
So there's some variables
that are beyond your control with altitude.
But if you're in shape, it's not that hard of a thing to do.
But this, 48 miles in two days,
I don't know, is that an ultra or is it
fake ultra.
Anything, I don't know.
It's a fake ultra.
Technically,
an ultra is defined as anything longer than a marathon,
but I don't know when you break it up, how that, who cares?
You know what I mean?
It's like-
You did a hard thing.
If you wanna put a label on it.
You know what it's like?
It's like, the breaking it up made it easier for sure.
No question about it.
And that was the accessibility that you were pointing out,
that's what's so cool about it.
And that it sneaks up on you.
'Cause you're like, I could do,
I could run four miles every four hours, slow.
But then, it incrementally,
the degree of difficulty gets notched up
in a second as the sleep slips away.
The second day is tough, second day is tough.
But like, I think there were a couple moments,
I think after the first 16 miles,
I looked up and I was like, okay, 32 to go.
You try not to check the scoreboard.
But then once you get past the first day-
Just focus on what's right in front of you to do,
which is get through those four miles.
And I rode my bike down on Saturday afternoon
to do a temp check on you.
You did.
And you were in good spirits
and April was out there with you pushing the baby
and you were all smiles and laughs.
Yeah, I mean, I try to keep it that way.
I think, look, a couple of things,
I didn't go into it saying I'm gonna try to do this.
I went into it feeling like I'm going to do this.
So it was never really,
and especially once I realized
how many people were paying attention,
there was no-
Yeah.
There was no graceful bailouts.
Yeah, then it becomes a whole other thing.
Which I did to myself, of course,
but I did it casually without realizing.
Well, that was part of me posting it on Instagram,
and the stories too, it's like, you can't back out, man.
This is like public.
Oh, I never was going to.
And in terms of like the why,
'cause Misty from Nantucket called in,
she's not gonna, we're not gonna play her question,
but her question was basically, did I find a why,
'cause I couldn't answer that.
And she said you scolded me.
And-
Did I scold you?
Well, she's-
I was challenging you.
You challenged me.
So my why, I still didn't really
figure it out in the moment.
Partly because the pacers
take some of that introspection away,
which I don't think is a bad thing.
It's just the way it goes.
When you have a friend next to you in life,
you're just not thinking about yourself as much.
But listening to Steven Pressfield on your podcast
and just thinking about what you guys
were talking about around finding your hero's journey
and going through that hard thing.
And thinking about my life,
which for a long time was defined by travel
and going to different cultures
and being kind of alone in those scenarios,
and having the pandemic come through
and that's completely wiped out,
and then of course life changes.
You know, I do think there was part of me
was just hungry for some tests like that, a test of self.
And so I do think that was like this subconscious pull.
I didn't realize it.
I didn't even think about it when I got her message.
I thought about it listening to you guys talk about it.
And I do think there's something there
that that was a call to action.
And to find out what was inside me, to see if I could do it.
And the fact that I could do it,
stay good humored and stay positive,
I think is a good feeling.
I'm satisfied with that answer.
I'm not gonna scold you on that.
I think what happens is, yeah, you have that pull,
that call to doing something hard, and then you do it.
And what that does is put another brick
in the wall of this identity that you craft
around being somebody who does hard things.
Like I do hard things, I can do hard things.
I'm not afraid of the degree of difficulty
or the unknown of something I've never experienced before.
I welcome that into my life.
And each one of those experiences that you have
is like another notch in the belt
that I think leads to greater self-esteem
and kind of how you navigate the world
in every other facet of your life.
I do feel like I got a self-esteem bump.
Like I felt it, like the next couple,
the day after, I was a bit of a wreck, and I had a deadline.
Did you ever have any like drowsy moments
where you were like short where they roll or like-
No.
No?
That's what happens with me.
Yeah, but I think part of that is I didn't
push myself to the edge in terms of pace.
I was very relaxed in my pace, so-
I was worried about you at one moment,
because you were talking about how your knee was acting up.
I just didn't want you to bury yourself and injure yourself,
because you felt the public pressure
of completing this thing.
Well, I would have kept going.
Even if the knee was a problem, I would have walked.
I wasn't gonna stop.
So when you work with David Goggins,
you don't stop when your knee cries a little bit.
And since you are working with David Goggins,
you couldn't have not done this anyway, right?
Well, I could have, I mean-
I mean,
David didn't put any pressure on you personally.
No, I brought it up to him,
and then once I brought it up to him,
it was basically a done deal.
Then it's over with.
(both laughs)
But he was really, I mean, let's put it this way.
In this time where everyone's so polarized
and at each other's throats, he creates this thing.
Some 30,000 people around-
Is that how many people?
Yeah, it's like in the 20 to 30 range and closer to 30,
signed up to do this thing,
this really hard thing altogether.
There's a real feeling of unity
among the people that were doing it, comradery.
And it just shows what, if you focus in versus focusing out,
the positive repercussions are, I think,
impossible to calculate, and it's just a ripple effect.
And so kudos to David for recognizing that,
seeing that, leading that.
And yeah, definitely, he was leading,
I was checking in with him
on his Instagram stories every time.
And then afterwards, I had a little debrief with him,
but not during.
During, I kind of was left to my own devices
and him to-
And he was doing
a bunch of pull-ups and push-ups in addition to all of this.
So yeah, so he was doing a combo of like a circuit,
because he's recovering from injury,
which I'm sure he'll get into at some stage.
But so he did-
So he wasn't running
'cause he's got to run-
He was on treadmill sometimes.
And then he was doing stair mat, he was doing a circuit.
Right, got it.
Yeah.
20 to 30,000 people.
I think it also speaks to,
we're in this moment where there's no races, right?
Normally, people would be signing up for this or that.
And without that being available to people,
they have turned to these virtual events,
and that kind of digital community
that can be created this way.
It's pretty cool.
It is cool.
And people raised millions of dollars
for different charities.
So everyone was kind of raising money
for their own various whatever.
Yeah, and he put out a story like last year,
he's always said, if running,
if you can't run, get on your bike.
If you can't bike, do whatever you can.
He pointed out to a guy who was 500 pounds
when he heard about this last year,
and his whole goal every four hours
was just to get up out of his chair
as many times he could every four hours.
And so he did that, a year later,
he's 300 pounds and he was running it.
Wow, that's cool.
So it just shows, you don't have to do it that way.
You could have done, if you have a Peloton at home,
go do that at a low pace,
or walk around the block 10 times, whatever it is.
So where does that leave you?
You've got some momentum now.
You just did this hard thing.
Does it make you enthusiastic to keep it up?
Continue it.
Or did you need to figure out another new challenge?
Well, yes.
So shout out also also to Nicholas Ramirez
who I've been talking to about my goals.
Your Enville coach.
The Enville coach,
the team, Enville, who's a champion swimrunner
and has this team, swimrun team called team Enville,
and you could join it for pretty cheap price
and he gives kind of group workouts,
or you could work with him personally
and he can give you some personalized stuff.
And I was telling him my goal.
One of my main goals is just to get faster at zone two.
And he told me this little tale that many years ago,
his whole thing was to try to get a sub-three marathon.
And it was like, took him to his ultimate limit
to barely get under sub-three.
And then last Saturday on an empty stomach,
a little bit hungover,
and just delivering something across town in Stockholm,
he decided to run there and back instead of driving.
Ran a marathon in zone two and a little bit
in zone three at under three hours.
And just the fact that the human body can do that,
and it just inspired me a bit more.
So I'm definitely interested
in continuing that zone two journey
to see how comfortable I can get running.
Because for so many years,
I was uncomfortable running, but do it anyway.
But in terms of activities,
we're looking at Cactus to Clouds.
Hopefully, my wife can break away from the baby
long enough to where we could do that together.
What is that?
That is a 10,000-foot elevation climb
from the desert to the top of San Jacinto peak
in Palm Springs.
Out in Palm Springs.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I'm thinking about that for the fall.
And then Otillo Catalina.
Right, that's in November, right?
That's in November.
Are the pools open in Santa Monica?
I wouldn't know.
Is Santa Monica
College open?
You never go to the, you never swim in the pool, do you?
I don't go to pools.
You might wanna think about that.
I know, that's my next talking to.
Team Enville might have an idea or two.
No, he doesn't mind me going in the ocean.
He's like, just do my drills in the ocean.
And I'm like so far, my drills are just swim there-
The great thing about Point Dume
is that it's the only like part of the coastline
in our vicinity that approximates a swimrun experience,
because you have that steep ascent
up the cliff and all of that.
Whereas most of the shoreline around here is very flat.
So it's hard to really get a proper swimrun workout
that's gonna approximate the kind of terrain
you're gonna have in one of those races.
Yeah, I mean, most of my, if I'm just swimming,
I usually just go right down in the Palisades somewhere.
But Dume is kind of, I did,
when I was training for Catalina,
I did use Dume and that's probably what I would do again.
Are you gonna do Catalina this year?
I think so.
I've done no swimming though.
Unlike you.
That's your,
you don't need to.
Yes I do.
Well, you will, but you don't need to now for November.
Yeah, I would like to be able to do that.
I mean, there are some pools open,
but you got to fill out these online forms
and schedule your time, way ahead of time.
And my week, the way it unfolds every day is different.
And I would go through periods
of filling out time slots throughout the week
and then only hitting like one out of the five or whatever.
And it's just, that's my own stuff or whatever.
There are pools open.
You just have to be,
I have to be a little bit more organized
about my training that I have then.
And they only let you in for like 45 minutes.
Right, and that's not enough for you.
Not enough.
But it's better than nothing.
You could do two miles in 45 minutes.
I've been really enjoying gravel riding.
That's been my thing lately.
So I'm just building a base on the bike right now
and exploring all these trails
that I've never experienced on two feet.
Like this whole world is opened up to me,
which has been really fun.
Maybe a sandy Tijuana to Vancouver ride is in your future.
I don't know what is in my future.
I do, shifting gears a little bit,
I do wanna shout out the Iron Cowboy.
Yes.
Today's Monday.
What's the date today?
The 12th?
No, 13th, 15th.
The 15th, today's the 15th.
James is on as of today, day 15 of his attempt
to do 100 Ironmans in 100 days.
He's been sharing all of this on Instagram.
The stories, I watch them every day, it's pretty cool.
To see him just get up every single day and do an Ironman.
He's been going strong and he's not without his challenges.
He, like, I think on like the third or fourth day,
his ankle had swollen up
such that anybody in their right mind
would have pulled the plug on this thing.
And he was just walking the marathons until,
in his mind, the way he articulated it,
like his body sort of clicked in
and adapted to what he was trying to do.
And now he's back to running.
And this is all happening on the outskirts of Provo, Utah.
So the other day, the whole thing,
it was snowing and sleeting like all day.
And he's out there with a smile on his face,
high vibes, tons of community.
It's cool to see so many people turn out
every single day to do a leg or a portion with him.
And he's getting it done.
Like the guy's just an absolute machine.
But I think most impressive is like this positive attitude
that he's, I mean, he's on his 15th consecutive Ironman,
but he's still got 85 to go.
Like, how do you, it's just unbelievable
to wrap your head around.
I know I have like a minuscule taste
of that kind of thinking though,
like that must be, in any ultra event, that's how it is.
You've done, you just-
Here we go.
You run, this is what we're doing.
You ran a marathon, now you have to run,
it's still 110 more to finish Badwater.
Right.
(laughs) It's crazy.
It's crazy.
He did have, I think with all the weather,
the inclement weather,
that definitely presented some challenges,
and he posted on Instagram a caption,
today, James Lawrence goes away
and the Iron Cowboy comes to life.
And I love that, that idea of the alter ego.
This is something that I spoke about
with Todd Herman, who's an author,
who was on the podcast a couple of years ago.
He wrote a book called "The Alter Ego Effect,"
which is all about this idea of kind of transposing
your identity into this superhuman avatar.
And this is something that David does, Goggins does, right?
It's like, there's David, and then there's Goggins.
And he goes into Goggins when he does these things.
Like, it's almost, it's not fair to call it a character,
but it's something outside of the self
that allows you to create like an arms length relationship
with the feat that you're trying to accomplish,
that I think is empowering and instructive
in terms of how you, and it's not like somebody told David,
create an alter ego for yourself or told James, create,
it's like, these were just natural
like survival tactics that they crafted
in order to survive these difficult challenges.
And I think it's cool, it's empowering as a means
of helping you exceed your sense of personal limitations.
So much love to James aka the Iron Cowboy.
Amazing, that's an amazing, amazing effort.
How long are his times?
Is he sharing his time?
Yeah, it's all on Strava and there's a live tracker,
and they're very transparent about all of it.
I mean, he's going slow.
His marathons are like six hours,
or five and a half hours or something,
or his bike ride's the same.
It's like, it's just about like,
look, I got the whole day to do this.
I just have to do it such that I get enough sleep-
That's enough, eight hours.
And recovery in between.
And he's got so much community around him.
Like tons of people are showing up every day.
And then in his house, he's got PTs
and his family and his kids are involved.
Like his daughter is always on the Instagram
talking about the live tracker
and where you can meet up with him.
So if anybody wants to go and support this guy,
you can just show up in Linden, Utah,
and go ride your bike with him or go run with him.
Incredible.
Really cool.
This party, you wanna get out there?
I might at some point, we'll see.
I mean, I did it last time when he was finishing his 50.
I showed up in Utah and ran the final marathon with him.
Amazing.
Either way,
whatever happens, he's definitely coming back
on the podcast to tell us about it if he survives.
No doubt.
And I have no doubt
that he will survive.
He's gonna make it.
Yeah, he is, it's incredible.
It is incredible.
I've never even heard of anything close to that.
Unbelievable, right?
And he's just banging them out.
Like, oh, another Ironman, another Ironman,
every single day.
It just becomes normal.
Yeah, on the same loop.
Like the mental drudgery of all of it as well.
You know, the same loop is good though.
Like I use the same loop for my,
I mean, terrible comparison,
but for my little thing-
Are you comparing yourself to the Iron Cowboy
right now?
I'm not, I'm not.
But the point is like, some people said
one piece of advice was used different routes,
but I found that I used one different route,
and it was just, it was actually distracting.
You always know what to expect and you can mark,
how you, like mentally, you take notes,
like, this is how I felt last time
when I crossed this intersection,
and this is how I feel now.
But again, thank you to everybody who support,
because like, I was really surprised.
And your community was like fully rallied.
It's a huge accomplishment, I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of Jason, Jason Camiolo, who also did it as well.
So lots of love here for all you-
It was nothing for him.
He's done 100-milers.
Yes, but his whole thing is like,
he just shows up and does it.
It's pretty impressive.
Which is its own form of very impressive.
I think he was worried about me after the midnight,
the second midnight when I didn't turn up.
Like, he's like, what happened to him?
Yeah, all right, well, let's take a break.
And we'll be back with the big story.
The big story.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you enjoy this podcast and I hope you're enjoying it,
then something tells me, I think you'll
really dig my latest book, "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50
of my favorite guests over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared therein,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP,
and also serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift or primer for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available.
And we're shipping globally direct
to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your coffee today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
All right, and we're back.
Adam.
Yes, sir.
Do you know what an NFT is?
I do now.
It's unbelievable
what's happening with all of this, isn't it?
It's literally unbelievable.
I could not believe it when I heard about it.
Right, I'm fascinated by this.
I wanted to do a little bit of a deep dive.
I will couch the conversation to come
with a disclaimer that I am the furthest thing
from an expert in the blockchain or anything crypto.
So this is definitely coming
from a layperson's perspective in every regard.
So to the extent that we get anything wrong here
and I'm sure that we will, don't at me with this.
Yeah, don't bother-
All the crypto heads who get off
'cause we've mis-characterized something here,
which I'm sure we will.
Don't bother us with our own ignorance.
We're aware.
Yes.
I'm self aware of my limitations.
All right, NFTs.
For people that don't know,
this is all about ownership rights to,
at least right now, digital art, ephemera, and media.
It's really one of the craziest
aspects of an already insane year.
And I think under, maybe not under-appreciated
or under-reported, but perhaps not discussed enough
is the complete upending of finance that we've been seeing,
not just with the insane swings of Bitcoin
and crypto and all these surges,
but also with the whole Robin Hood GameStop thing,
and the kind of crowdsourcing
of energy around stock purchases,
the advent of SPACs,
which are special purpose acquisition companies
that are like the new hot thing in M and A.
We don't need to get into all that,
but like, there's a lot of interesting things happening-
Yeah, but can I say something
about that?
In finance right now.
SPACs, like there was literally the Jay-Z story
about how he started his own SPAC
and all the stars were doing it.
And then immediately, it's wiped off the front pages
of business when the NFT story breaks.
Like, you're not even hearing about them anymore.
There's a lot of SPAC activity, though.
And I only know the very surface level
of like what all of that entails,
but we're gonna talk about NFTs today.
What is an NFT?
So an NFT is, it's funny.
I was riding bikes with a buddy of mine the other day
who's a big private equity guy,
and I was like, let's talk about NFTs.
And I started talking, and he was like,
I don't know what that is.
And I'm like, you're a money guy.
Like, it's amazing, like this finance guy,
this was like news to him,
which made me more enthusiastic
about talking about it today,
because I think there's a lot of people
that really have either never heard of this
or only caught a headline about crazy price
that was paid for a piece of digital art.
So, an NFT, NFT stands for non-fungible token.
It's an asset verified using blockchain technology
in which a network of computers records transactions
and gives buyers proof of authenticity and ownership.
The current boom is mostly for digital assets
like images, gifs, songs, videos.
And it's different from crypto in that crypto is fungible.
You can use it as a mode of,
you can use it as a currency, as a method of exchange,
but an NFT cannot be traded at equivalency.
'Cause it's unique, it's one of one.
And in diving into the history of all of this,
I don't know about you, but the first time
that I came across an NFT was watching "Feels Good Man"
when it got to the rare Pepes thing.
And I was like, what is this?
I didn't quite put it together there.
And then it jumps to this story with Beeple,
which we'll get into,
but like that's when it kind of first hit my face.
But now that you mentioned it, yes,
we heard about it in "Feels Good Man,"
but I just didn't think about it.
And I thought like, well,
that's gotta be the craziest most fringe thing ever.
And in the period of time
in between that documentary and now,
like it's become a completely different can of worms.
Now, Matt should drop Pepe-
I think that he is.
Like those guys did post something,
I wish I'd looked that up before we were talking today,
but they posted something on Instagram
about how somebody did an NFT
around something related to Pepe and it got,
it garnered an amount of money
that would have financed their entire movie.
But Matt should make all of his artwork,
even the print that he gave to the studio here, to us,
that should definitely be an NFT.
Oh, here it is.
Rarest Pepe, most important NFT in art history.
I'm looking it up right now, and it sold for 320 grand.
Wow, yeah.
So real money is getting exchanged for these things.
And diving into the history of all of this,
like all things internet, of course it started with cats,
because everything important
about the internet begins with cats.
And ends with, it's going to end with cats.
With cats, right?
So the technology has been around since the mid-2010s,
but it didn't hit the mainstream
until around 2017 with CryptoKitties,
which was a site that allowed people
to buy and breed, quote unquote breed
limited edition digital cats with cryptocurrency.
Oh my God.
Right?
Which sounds so weird, but fast forward to now,
and Christie's is auctioning people's piece of art,
and it goes for, how much did it go for?
63-
69 million.
$69 million.
And I was trying to wrap my head around what that means.
Like what exactly is being conveyed in terms of ownership?
What's interesting is there is no acquisition
of trademark or copyright or even sole ownership.
It's really bragging rights and knowledge
that your copy, if you purchase something,
is the quote unquote authentic one,
which is a mind bender, given that these works
don't exist in the three-dimensional world.
These are digital works that are easily replicated.
Like you could just take that JPEG
and copy it a bazillion times, slide it onto your desktop.
But it's the idea that this is the authentic one
and it's locked on the blockchain.
And you're the one who has the certificate
of authenticity or ownership of that.
The internet is the museum.
The art is in the museum of the internet,
and everyone can see it because they're also at the museum,
but you're the one that owns it.
Right.
Right,
which is still weird.
It's still, yeah, it's like,
it bends the noodle completely.
Yeah, like why?
Right?
What's also interesting is that
you can then sell portions of it like a stock.
You could sell like a percentage of ownership of your NFT
to a variety of people.
So it becomes like,
like the mortgage.
Well, yeah.
I mean, it becomes a financial asset
in a very interesting way, I think.
And as a 54-year-old man
trying to wrap his head around this,
it's very easy to be dismissive or cynical
or just think this is all insanity.
But when you think about it, this is the future.
And I think it portends much more
than a change in how we think about the art world.
It really brings up a broader conversation
about what ownership means in the digital age
as we slowly progress towards this matrix-like existence.
Exacerbated, of course, by the pandemic
where we're all at home and we're living
our lives more and more online than ever.
So rather than going to the fancy store
and buying a wristwatch that's gonna impress your friends,
the digital version of that is owning
a piece of artwork on the blockchain.
Right, because you-
In the digital world,
because we're all interacting digitally now.
Right, and it's interesting that you're saying that,
it's like, because if it changes the way,
like would you rather own a piece of a multinational company
or some digital art piece and trade that as your commodity?
You know what I mean?
Like it changes what commodities are too.
It actually democratizes art ownership in ways
if they're gonna start taking away pieces
of the $69 million thing and you can own a piece of it.
'Cause I don't think you can do that
with art on a wall anymore or before.
I don't know, I think it's interesting.
It's,
at the same time,
it's kind of like the epitome of manufactured need.
But that's what all consumer goods are on some level.
Like if you look at, like, look at the companies
that are thriving particularly during the pandemic,
and they're the ones that are very good
at manufacturing demand by sort of messaging
around limited supply, like a sneaker drop.
Like the sneaker that goes for $500
because it's a limited run costs the same to manufacturer
as the one that's at the outlet store.
It's like $5 of plastic or whatever.
And you know-
That's a great comparison.
And yet one is lauded and coveted and the other one
is basically considered not valuable at all, why is that?
It's all imagined.
Right, like it's like baseball card values.
It's all, but baseball card values-
But baseball cards are limited,
because there's only so many players.
Because like the Honus Wagner card,
which is the most valuable card,
he only allowed a certain amount to be printed
because he didn't wanna do business
with a cigarette companies.
And so he, and so because of that,
it was this need that was created by the moment.
And there's only a few and in all other cases,
there's so many, but only a few survive
because people throw them away.
And so then it becomes collectible,
or like the same idea with,
what's it called action figures and that kind of market.
And in sneakers, similar idea.
But in the digital landscape,
there's no limitation on supply.
It could be anything.
And right now, all the attention is around art.
And in particular, this work by this artist called Beeple.
He's got this piece called "The First 5,000 Days."
It's a collage of 5,000 images that he created
like using some kind of, he's like a digital artist.
Each one of these little images
that are a composite of this larger work
are all very interesting in their own right.
Christie's, the white shoe auction house auctioned off,
it's not the first time that they've auctioned off an NFT,
but it's definitely the biggest one that they've done.
And this thing went for 69.3 million.
It was purchased using Ethereum,
which is the preferred crypto for NFTs
in this NFT like economy by, I mean,
it just gets weirder, by a guy called Metakovan.
Like we don't even know his real name.
He claims that he got it at a steal.
And that makes Beeple the third
highest selling artists alive.
Right, and no one had ever heard of Beeple.
I mean, street artists did.
People in the digital art world knew who he was,
but it's not like Jackson Pollack or Picasso.
No, Picasso.
No, Picasso never did that well on one piece,
I don't think, until he died.
He missed the NFT boom.
Yeah, I think you've hit the nail on the head
with the pandemic playing into this,
because our galleries were closed,
our dealers didn't know what to do.
Artists didn't have an outlet
to sell their wares in any way.
NFT has created a way for digital artists
to sell something without having to put in a gallery.
And not only sell something, but sell something
at such a high price point that they never had before.
And so now everyone's, look, Pepe the Frog,
everyone's going for it, 'cause it's a gold rush.
There's one aspect to it
that is getting a little bit of buzz,
but not as much as like the big price tags.
I had something I never knew was native
to blockchain and all cryptocurrency,
but just the fact that there is a huge
carbon footprint associated with blockchain.
Which I never knew about really
until I started looking into this.
Basically the idea of mining,
which is what you do when you have,
when you're creating cryptocurrency
or any sort of blockchain,
is you have a huge amount of computer power
being sucked by this network of computers
that are running millions and millions of cryptographs,
which is basically checking each block
in the chain for sequencing errors,
making sure they're all original and minting a transaction.
A transaction, meaning here's this new string
of letters and numbers that is completely unique.
Blockchain is being used, not just in art, in currency,
it's been used, there's people who wanna use it for voting,
there's people who wanna use it for,
or it is being used in fisheries right now
to be able to authenticate where a certain harvest
is coming from and which fishery, I know that's happening.
So the fact that it's being used all this way
and there is a carbon footprint is interesting.
Ethereum is really bad.
It's not the worst of the cryptocurrencies,
but it's really bad when it comes to its carbon footprint.
And a Turkish digital artist, Memo Akten,
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly,
with a PhD in artificial intelligence.
So a pretty smart dude.
He started seeing everything in the NFTs
and he was excited about it like everybody else.
And then he started looking into the crypto carbon footprint
and what he found out was a single NFT transaction
demands the same amount of energy
an average European Union household
would need for an entire month.
Right, the average NFT.
So that's gonna run the gamut, of course, but-
Right, but the-
The main point just being that, like,
there's a huge carbon footprint here.
And it just seems like, oh, it's all happening digitally.
And what we don't see is what's powering this whole thing,
which, well, demands a tremendous amount of energy
and computing power.
Right.
And the sum of all these 18,159 NFTs
has consumed an average EU resident's
electricity consumption of 2,000 years,
using a laptop for 54,000 years,
boiling a kettle 78 million times.
I mean, just crazy, and this is all
from Memo's great Medium post.
There's another artist who,
a French artist who became a climate activist.
His name is Joanie Lemercier, and he's based out of Belgium.
And he's been an artist for a long time, digital artist,
has has his own studio in Belgium,
but when he became a climate activist,
he uses art to kind of highlight issues with climate.
Then he dropped some NFTs and he was approached by Memo
and explained what was happening and how it kind of impacts.
'Cause he's taken his studio and he's done a lot of work
on that studio to make it as energy efficient as possible.
And he found out that his first NFT drop
consume more energy in 10 seconds
than his studio had it almost two years.
Wow.
So like,
it's a crazy amount of energy.
Yeah.
Who knew?
For something that doesn't exist in the real world.
For something that doesn't exist.
That just bends the noodle even further
to even like appreciate or understand that,
that just because something is online,
like we think it's just, there's a seamlessness to it.
And there's no kind of real world repercussions to it, but-
There's real repercussions,
but there's no real world thing.
Right, yeah, exactly, which is even weirder.
I do know that Ethereum is working
or planning to cut this absurd energy consumption
with plans to reduce it by 99%.
I don't know enough about blockchain
to know how that would be accomplished
or how realistic that is.
I would suspect though, with advances
in technology and creating greater scale,
that they will figure this out at some point.
Do you have a sense of where things stand with that?
So basically, the pushback from Ethereum and SuperRare,
which is one of the platforms where you can,
where you can buy these NFTs is that if you read that,
you're assuming that there's no carbon footprint
associated with regular art dealing, which there is
with miles of travel and airfare and all that.
But in reality, that still would pale
in comparison to what's happening.
Ethereum has a new software they've been working on.
I think it's called 2.0.
They wanna cut their carbon footprint.
This new software will allow them to do that.
It's not out yet.
There's no, you know, two years ago they were told,
people were told it was happening.
And now it's two years away from being two years away,
which is probably where it stands.
So I'm not an expert in that.
I can't really say when it will be available,
but they're not saying it's coming around the corner.
So they're saying they're working on it.
Right, hopefully they'll figure that out.
The idea is if it scales,
it should be able to be worked out.
But that's like the excuse we use
for a lot of things as human beings.
It's, yes, it's a problem now,
but when it scales, it's gonna be a lot easier.
This is something I talked about
with Alex on the podcast the other day.
That's an argument that comes
up to poo-poo renewables, right?
Because when you have a renewable,
you still have to sort of supplant the old technology
and there's gonna be a carbon footprint to that
that's gonna exceed what it will eventually become
if you just continue to push it forward.
That's part of the evolution as well.
It's like a transaction cost that's built into it.
I don't know-
Well, that's what they say.
That's what the SuperRare people,
the SuperRare people are saying that same thing is that,
like people are using the climate deal
as an excuse to not change the world.
But my question would be,
do you know how this world changes from here?
Because what happens is,
it's the unintentional consequences of good intentions.
Like I'm not saying the intention
is to ruin the environment.
I'm saying it's an unintended consequence
of something that they think is great for the world.
And that is like basically the recipe
for a lot of disasters that we've had.
So the idea of thinking 100 years down the line
is not something that's happening in Silicon Valley.
And never has in America really,
since the native cultures are kind of subjugated.
'Cause that, thinking of what happens after you're gone
three generations, seven generations later, right,
seven generations, that's something that we don't do.
It would be nice to start doing that
considering where we're at
in the environment and climate crisis.
The energy around NFTs has been
in the context of art and the art world.
But I think what's more interesting,
that's just like NFT 1.0,
which is where we're at right now.
With pieces being auctioned,
there's all these sites where you can, they call it minting.
Like you can upload your work
and then hold it out for sale or auction.
All these sites like foundation.app.
But we're also seeing Twitter posts being turned into NFTs.
Jack Dorsey turned his first tweet into an NFT
and it's at like 2.5 million for charity.
Logan Paul did a run of like collectible cards.
And musicians, Deadmou5, Grimes, Steve Aoki, Kings of Leon.
3LAU, this guy like got 11.7 million on NFTs
related to like an old album
where he was also providing access to new music
and like a vinyl version of some of his work.
So I think that it's, we're gonna see it expand
into other areas of creative expression
beyond just like digital visual arts.
So like the first episode of the Rich Roll Podcast?
And I think, well, it's funny,
'cause I thought about that.
Like Kevin Roose just launched
a new podcast called Modern Finance,
which is all about like crypto and NFTs.
And he made that initial episode an NFT,
and I thought, oh, it'd be cool.
Maybe I should make the very first episode
of this podcast an NFT.
The environmental considerations that get packed into that
are probably going to prevent me from doing that right now.
But it would be cool, right,
just to experiment and see what would happen.
I really wanna understand the environment
implications of that before I do that.
But I think where we're gonna see value
is in artists or creators who create an NFT
that isn't just the thing itself,
but also packed into it
are all these other kind of benefits.
Like if you're a band or a musician,
if you purchase this limited run of NFTs,
you also get a backstage pass or you get,
you'll get access to the new music first
or all these other things
that can be built into the blockchain.
Because part of what the benefit of the blockchain is
is you can create these contracts
that work in lockstep with technology.
So when X happens, then Y gets this.
And as we see this kind of ecosystem
become more robust and mature,
I think the broader implications on culture beyond just,
oh, this painting, this digital
work of art sold for this much,
is gonna be impacting all of us.
And I think to kind of telescope out even more,
it's an interesting philosophical
exploration of what ownership means.
We were talking about supply and demand.
Like how do we think about the material world
and the digital world in terms of our relationship to it?
And this is bringing up a new way of seeing all of that.
And I find that to be like endlessly fascinating.
I mean, there are these guys called Burnt Banksy
that own Banksy paintings, or at least one of them,
and like burned the Banks, like scanned a work of Banksy,
burned the original and then minted the scan as an NFT
and sold it for like three times the value of the actual
original physical three-dimensional piece of art.
So what does that tell you
about how we think about ownership and value?
What does it tell you?
Well, I think that it's changing.
I think that we're, I think it's,
I think that it is an indication
that we are inching closer and closer to the matrix.
We're entering into this liminal space
between the material world and the digital world
where we're grappling with how we want to live our lives.
Are we living them here
in the here and now in the tactile world?
Or are we living them as avatars in this digital space?
And the pandemic has accelerated something
that I think was an inevitability,
but the fact that we're seeing more people
value these things in the digital space
more than they value things in the real world
is a very interesting concept.
It's fascinating because like really in the end,
you and I can still go and see these same things
online with a click of the mouse.
Right.
And-
But the argument is you can see,
you can do that with the "Mona Lisa" as well.
But you have to go to the Louvre.
Well, yeah, but you can see a JPEG of it.
Right.
Like, why would you,
why do people line up in front of the "Mona Lisa"
and take a photo of it?
It's Leonardo da Vinci's charisma.
Is that what it is?
You know what I mean?
Like there's plenty of photos of it.
It's, yeah, what really-
And why would you wanna own
that painting when there images of it,
and you could, with one click, you can find,
you can enjoy an image of the "Mona Lisa"?
Like what-
So how is this different?
It's like, our art is freighted
with history and stories, right?
So we're told things about where a piece of art
comes from and who made it and all that
together creates certain amount of value,
right, plus the rarity aspect of it.
And I guess the same thing is true in the digital world.
I just have a hard time, like,
'cause you can also get an NFT of sports highlights,
and they're selling for a lot of money.
Like a lot of money,
like millions of dollars in NBA highlights.
Right, the NBA.
So you can own
a highlight, like a poster.
Like I used to put a Michael Jordan poster on my wall.
I can now own a Michael Jordan highlight in NFT.
But what is that?
Like, I can go on-
What is the value
of being the original certified,
authentic owner of that clip?
In my estimation, it's zero.
Like, that does nothing for me in my life.
But you know-
Could the argument, and I'm just saying this
from a perspective of being a devil's advocate,
how is that different from owning the Mona Lisa
when it's a ubiquitous image?
Yeah, that's a good question.
It goes back to feeling and ego
more than anything else, right?
The ownership ego.
Yeah.
I think there's also a crypto punk sensibility
that's at play here too.
Like let's blow up the system and we're gonna,
Mr. Ethereum gajillionaire is gonna buy this digital work
for an insane amount of money as like an F you
to everything you ever thought about the art world.
Because he can.
And that's very punk rock.
It is.
And there's something cool about that also.
Like let's blow up the system
and just re-imagine this entire structure.
And it's all online and digital and it's unhackable.
'Cause that's the idea is like a blockchain,
that's why it's good is that it's unhackable, right?
You can't hack it.
But it's also important to understand
that this is very early days,
and there's no question that this is like a crazy bubble.
It's like internet 1.0, right?
This is gonna blow up.
There's some people that are gonna make a lot of money
and there's gonna be a lot of people
that are gonna lose a lot of money,
and this will sort itself out and over time
mature into a more kind of robust ecosystem.
But right now, I find it to be very,
like if you were gonna spend an insane amount of money
on a digital work of art right now, like that is so risky.
Crazy risky, right?
I agree.
So Seth Godin wrote about this.
I don't know if you saw his piece.
He's basically saying,
the title is NFTs are a dangerous trap,
which is basically walking you through this bubble idea.
Yeah, he thinks it's a bubble.
And there's another aspect of it that's dangerous.
And that even though the NFT itself
will be certified as one of one,
you actually don't know if the seller's the creator.
So there's a rights aspect to it,
because what's lagging behind
is the authenticity of the seller.
Because right now, people are using avatars
and handles and you don't know who they are.
But I do think, if there's another thing
to celebrate about all of this,
it's the empowerment of the creator, right?
Like the artist no longer has to be hat in hand.
It puts the creator of artistic works
in more of control over the destiny
of the work that they create.
And it allows them to get value for it.
And this can be anything.
Like you could write a series of short stories
or a book and do a limited run as NFTs.
Like there's so many different variations on this
that I think we're gonna start seeing.
So this is just the very beginning.
And I think it's only gonna continue
to get more and more fascinating.
So like the "On the Road" scroll as NFT?
"On the Road" scroll,
what is that?
You know that,
there was a famous,
Jack Kerouac glued or taped pages together
so that when he was writing high on Benzedrine,
his first draft of "On the Road"
like came spooling out of him
in a matter of like a couple of weeks or something.
And he had it on a scroll so that he never had to add paper
to his typewriter and he just kept going, kept going.
And that scroll ended up getting edited down
over the course of months or over a year
and it became the manuscript.
But that scroll itself was,
and the scroll itself was republished eventually,
but it was bought by a collector.
The guy who owns the Indianapolis Colts bought it.
And he, and the scroll has all the characters
as the people who they really were,
Jack and Cassidy and all those.
And so that scroll is the original, 'cause it's one of one.
Right, but that's the antithesis
of what we're talking about.
Because that is like a relic that exists in the real world.
But you were saying like an author could do that
with his first manuscript, could mint it-
Or anything.
Like an author right now could just say,
I'm not gonna publish my book with a traditional publisher.
I'm gonna make it an NFT.
And whoever wants to buy it can buy it.
And then-
But if you're,
what if Malcolm Gladwell said,
my next book is gonna be an NFT.
And then the on pub day, he uploads it,
he mints it on one of these sites, and then that's it.
It exists in the digital world so you can copy it, right?
But who, would that auction,
would that go for a lot of money?
I bet it would.
Just one of one, just publishing one copy of his book.
And then let it replicate out.
Yeah, and then let it replicate out
and see what would happen.
Would he still have the rights to-
Yeah, because he's not transferring copyright.
So it doesn't give the owner,
the buyer permission to replicate it.
Just have the-
Only a certification
that they have the authentic original copy of this.
Even though originality is like the wrong word,
because something that exists in ones and zeros
that can be duplicated with absolute precision
begs the question of what original means to begin with.
Hmm, you are bending
my noodle right now.
Do you think
if Kerouac was around now that he would be into crypto?
No.
And like NFTs?
No, I don't. (laughs)
All right, maybe we've talked enough about this for now.
Anyway, I'm gonna be keeping an eye on this.
I think it's super interesting.
This came up with my conversation with Kevin Roose too.
'Cause he was like, I wanna learn more about this.
I wanna write about this.
I was like, you should write a book about NFTs
and release it as an NFT.
And it would be like this weird Charlie Kaufman adaptation,
like meta experiment.
Was he into it?
I don't know, maybe, we'll see.
You know, it does show that like,
we had talked about on the phone earlier,
where it's just like, it's the cleaving of culture from,
you're right about that.
The crowbar of the digital world
is cleaving culture from the original owners.
So the creators, but creators narrowly defined,
like the creators that choose
certain new mediums are the beneficiaries.
And then people like your buddy, the hedge funder,
or my friend, the screenwriter, or whoever,
these people who are used to things the way they used to be,
and all of a sudden they don't even know,
PewDiePie on YouTube is the most powerful person in media,
whatever, or Joe Rogan is in podcasts.
And when they hip to it,
that train has already left the station,
and they're gonna do everything that is in their power
to hold onto the reins of the traditional mechanisms.
Because all of this is a threat to business as usual.
And that's frightening.
If you're like, when I see Christie's
doing what they just did with Beeple,
like they're trying to be current and modern
with where all of this is going.
But if you're the competitor, a stodgy auction house,
and you're like NFTs, that's bullshit, we're not doing that,
you're gonna get pushed out and antiquated pretty quickly,
because this is where culture is heading.
And the fact that this has been around for 10 years,
and it's now hitting this really interesting
and strange inflection point,
but the blockchain is not going away
and it's gonna continue to revolutionize so many of,
it's not just crypto and it's not just art.
Like it's gonna have massive implications
on how we do pretty much everything.
Yeah, it already is in different ways.
This is, in this way, it's like
it still has that whiff of individuality.
Individualism, not individuality, individualism
of look at me, look what I own,
and which the internet is really good at.
Right, I know.
Can you imagine having enough Ethereum lying around
that you could just shed $69 million worth of it
for a piece of digital art?
I mean, how much Ethereum does Metakoven have
that he can do that, right?
Well, less now.
Which is insane.
Because you know,
if you were hoarding crypto way back in the day,
like the amount of money that a lot of these people
have right now is absolutely bananas.
Do you have crypto?
No, I had like three or four Bitcoin years ago
when I pick them up for like under,
when it was like under 1,000,
and then I was broke and I had to get rid
of all of it to like pay some bills, but I never.
And I have friends way back
who were always telling me,
you should be doing Bitcoin.
It's always that like FOMO meets it's too late,
because now it's so high,
but I think it's gonna continue to go up.
I know, when,
there was a period when we bought
a little bit of crypto and we're like, we don't want,
even Ethereum was like, it was so high,
like you end up with like a couple of Ethereum
or something like that, yeah, or percentages of Bitcoin.
Instead, we're like, no, let's find the one that might pop.
So we have Ripple, but it hasn't popped.
Well, I have other friends that spend
way too much time just watching the graphs all day
and trading in all these smaller cryptos
and then putting it into Bitcoin,
and it monopolizes all their time and energy.
Exactly.
Anyway.
I'd rather be in the ocean.
Right, well you're, yeah, okay, boomer.
That's the ultimate okay, boomer.
All right, let's switch gears here.
We have a little news piece here
that I know you wanted to share about.
Yes.
Just a few minutes about it.
I don't know if you've been keeping tabs,
but there are mass protests in Myanmar.
They've been going on for quite a while.
Myanmar is a country in Southeast Asia.
It borders Thailand, China, India, Bangladesh.
And I've covered it quite a bit.
There's been humanitarian crisis in Myanmar for generations.
Basically, what happened after World War II.
It was an English colony, after World War II,
General Aung San tried to get all of these
different ethnicities that were all part
of this country called Burma at the time,
to come together in a democratic self-governing way.
And he got all these different warring militias
and ethnicities to come together
with the majority Burman population,
and then he was murdered right on the eve
of the constitution kind of happening.
And ever since then, the military
has controlled the country in various degrees.
And for much of our lifetime,
it's been a straight up military dictatorship.
I've covered it in that these,
the same military has been running people
off their native lands and exploiting
the natural resources for private gain.
And what I mean private gain, I mean,
they're actually taking,
the generals are actually taking money
and just filling their bank accounts with it.
And you know, the crisis, anyway,
so fast forward to 2007, 2008,
there was a big uprising.
Aung San Suu Kyi was under house arrest at the time
and she was the freedom fighter.
And there were mass protests then,
but they were stomped down pretty quickly
by the military government.
But a few years later,
they decided to allow for voting again.
And so they've allowed
the political parties to engage in debate.
And 25%, I believe of the parliamentary seats
are reserved for the military,
but everyone else is competing and voting.
That was the way it was.
And Aung San Suu Kyi, this hero was elected president,
she's been president ever since then.
But then on February 1st,
after another landslide victory for the NLD,
National League of Democracy, which is Suu Kyi's party,
she was arrested along with other leaders in the NLD.
And the military took over again
for the first time in years.
And basically, they've been using all sorts
of cybersecurity technology to crack down
on pro-democracy activists and party leaders.
And people have taken to the streets
ever since February 1st.
And at first, there was tolerance
of these peaceful protests,
but then rubber bullets came out, tear gas came out,
and now they're literally shooting into crowds
and dozens of people have been murdered by security forces.
And that's where it's at right now.
What is America's foreign policy stance towards Myanmar?
So for years, when the military was in charge
and Suu Kyi was under house arrest for,
Aung San Suu Kyi is the daughter of General Aung San.
And so she was this hero that came,
that rose up at different times to speak truth to power.
She became this, she won the Nobel Peace Prize.
As president, she's had her own problems,
because of what's been happening with the,
why am I spacing out, the Rohingya population.
She was in power when the Myanmar military
was running the Rohingya off their land,
and she didn't speak up for the Rohingya at all.
And all of a sudden people were calling
for her Nobel Prize back.
So she's kind of, she sided
with the military in certain ways.
And she was doing that, I think,
to preserve peaceful power-sharing, but it didn't work.
So not only did she sell her soul,
but then she ends up getting under house arrest.
And so for years,
when she was under house arrest the first time,
it was a sanctions policy.
So we sanctioned the Myanmar.
We weren't helping them whatsoever.
We were helping with some humanitarian stuff
in the ethnic states that were at war,
'cause there was an active war.
There were militias in Shan State or Kayin State,
where I visited many times going to see
displaced people in their displaced people's camps,
spending time with rebel military, there was active war.
And there was some aid, but for largely our stance
with the Myanmar government was sanctions.
And then when Obama was in power
and they gave power back to the people in various degrees.
At first it was like 50% of the parliamentary seats,
and then it was 25%.
Obama was engaging.
And not just Obama, but Europe too.
Europe started engaging with Myanmar.
Myanmar's economy was growing
and it was actually a really vibrant place to be,
'cause the people are wonderful
and they want to engage and they wanna grow.
And they just want freedom.
And now, it looks like it's coming back
to where it used to be where certain people
get rich and everyone else suffers.
And what is, is the UN doing anything about this?
Right now, everyone's sitting on their hands.
Like, what can you do short of invading?
Like, what can you do?
And we never did invade because China has interests there.
For the UN to come up with a peacekeeping force,
you need to get, the UN Security Council
needs to vote in favor.
And any one dissenting vote kills the resolution.
So that means China.
China does business with Burma, or Myanmar.
And China's not alone, but yeah.
So how does this play out in your estimation?
That's a good question.
I'm kind of flagging it just so people
kind of pay attention to what's happening.
Thanks to, right now, at first,
after the coup and I think it's still happening,
the news got cut off, cable got cut off,
internet access was spotty, you have to find it.
In all of Yangon, the major city,
there was one hotel that had
internet access for a little bit.
I don't know.
I've been thinking of the business owners there
and what they're going through and what they're thinking.
Like, imagine sinking your life savings
into a business there.
You can't leave,
because there's no money to leave with.
Is there, is there any egress though?
Are there refugees that are fleeing?
I have not heard of mass refugees fleeing yet,
but if they do, it'll be the Thailand border.
That's how I always accessed it.
I would go to Thailand and then get
into the ethnic provinces from there,
which a lot of journalists do.
And you can do it legally.
So we'll see.
There's already refugee camps on the Thailand border
that have stood for 20, 30 years.
But people have left them and gone back
and started businesses and done well.
But now, it's all coming back around.
And those same villages that people went back to
are getting overrun by military again now.
All right, well, we'll keep an eye on this.
Yeah, sorry, I feel like I'm talking too loud.
I think you're all right.
Okay.
Jason will modulate you.
You'll end up sounding like butter.
Let's do some listener questions.
Let's do it.
Hey guys,
this is will from Portland, Oregon.
I had a question.
I was a vegan for awhile.
I was inspired by Rich when he first started the podcast.
I read your memoir and all that.
And did my first marathon about seven years ago.
Shortly after that, my father passed away,
and as life happens, you kind of just lose all motivation
and I stopped being vegan, stopped running completely.
And I'm a lot heavier than I used to be.
And I just wanted to know for heavier folks
who are trying to get back into the game or just start it,
there's not a lot of information out there of how to do it.
It's hard to ego check yourself
and know that you can't do what you once used to do.
I just wanted to know if you guys had any advice
on starting over for folks who have kind of lost it all
and are trying to grasp the reality
of where we're at and where we once were
and just the mind game that that plays sometimes.
Thank you guys so much.
I love listening to you guys, big fan, bye.
Thanks for your question, Will.
That's a good question.
I think it's a question that a lot of people can relate to.
And I have a few thoughts on this.
I mean, first of all, the only day better
than yesterday to begin something like this is today, right?
And the good news is, you've done it before.
So you actually already know what to do.
You mentioned that there's not a lot
of information out there on how to do it.
I disagree.
I think there's plenty of information.
I don't think that we're thirsting
for information that doesn't exist
on how to make this kind of transformation.
So information, in my opinion, you did this before,
you read my book, you went vegan, you ran a marathon.
Like information is not your malfunction.
Action is your problem.
And I think that you're a victim
of your own kind of shame at the moment.
So my suggestion is to find a way to bury that shame spiral
and to put an end to the pity party and just begin
by putting one foot in front of the other.
What is right in front of you to do right now?
Can you go out the door and go for a walk?
What is your next meal gonna be?
And I think with that, with those tiny steps,
you start to create a little bit of momentum.
And there's huge power in momentum.
If you can create just the tiniest positive change
that's a little bit different from your daily MO,
that will help free you
from this position that you're in right now,
which is being stuck in a negative cycle.
So the focus should be on, what can you do right now?
You can't run a marathon.
You haven't been vegan for a while.
You put on a bunch of weight.
You can go for a walk, you can eat a salad,
and you can celebrate those tiny wins
until you slowly get more emotionally
connected to this arc of improvement.
And with that, the path will present itself.
You don't need somebody to deliver you
an information packet with your plan for the next two years.
What you need to do is to take action.
And I think, at odds with that right now,
this enemy that you're facing
is comparing yourself to this person
that you were seven years ago.
Comparison is the thief of joy.
So stop comparing yourself
to your past self or to other people.
It's this idea of not training
where you think you should be.
Like, if you go out for a jog
and you get tired after a block
and you feel like you have to walk,
and then you're beating yourself up
because I used to run a marathon,
and look at how much weight I put on.
It's not about that.
It's not about training where you think you should be.
It's about accepting and embracing where you are right now
and doing what you are capable of doing,
because that's the only way
that you get anything done or make any progress.
So you have everything you need.
And I think you need to disabuse yourself of this idea
that you're gonna stay in your status quo
until you experience some windfall of motivation.
Like you're waiting to be motivated.
Like you've said, I just don't feel motivated,
I don't have any motivation.
And I think when you're in that mindset,
you're waiting to feel motivated to do something.
And that's not how it works.
That's in fact, a trap.
You don't need to be motivated to make change.
You just need to do.
Mood follows action, which is what I always say.
So a day at a time, just like they say in 12 step.
What can you do today?
Can you eat a little bit better?
Can you move your body in a way that you didn't yesterday?
Can your head hit the pillow
with a little bit more self-esteem
because you exercise some self-care
and some self-love by moving the needle
ever so slightly in the right direction?
And when you start to string some days together
of doing just that, it doesn't take long
before you wake up a little bit more excited
for that walk that turns into a jog
that eventually over time will turn into a run
and just might bring you back
to the starting line of another marathon.
I love it.
It reminds me of like, baseball season's around the corner.
It reminds me of like those hitters that are in a slump.
What do they do is they just focus
on their approach to each at-bat,
because you can't control getting a hit,
'cause there's so many bad bounces
or the way the ball, you just don't know.
The balls and strikes are called differently every day.
But can you change your approach to each at-bat
and then start stringing some good ones together?
And sort of then eventually you start seeing
a couple of hits and the momentum turns
and your confidence turn.
Yeah, I mean, I just can't stress
the importance of tiny little actions.
Like if Will's running shoes are in the closet,
pull them out of the closet and put them in the hallway.
Like, if all you did was that,
well, that's more than you did yesterday.
Next time, put them next to your bed.
The next day, like, why don't you put them on
when you sit up in the morning,
and like, walk to your front door?
Like, what can you do?
And then do those tiny things
that are very digestible and doable,
count them as wins and build on that momentum.
That's a great advice.
And the fact that you're listening, Will,
shows that you're still,
your head's still in the game.
Of course.
All right.
We're going to Europe for this one.
Hey Rich and Adam.
This is Tanya from Lucerne, Switzerland.
I would love to hear your thoughts on this topic.
So I've been living plant-based for over five years.
I try to mostly buy things secondhand.
I always stop to question
if what I wanna buy is something that I really need.
And I do this partly because I'm really concerned
for our planet's future and its resources,
but also because I have a one-year-old kid
and I really want him to grow up living consciously
and making deliberate choices.
So I try really hard to remind myself
that I'm in control only of myself.
I often struggle with older people from other generations
who live very frivolously with like seemingly little concern
about the impact they're having on the planet.
I know that grandparents can have
a massive influence on their grandchildren.
So have you found good talking points to address this?
Or do you just try to not think about it too much
and let people live how they want to?
Thanks so much.
Tanya from Lucerne.
Yes, Lucerne in the house.
Isn't that where they make the butter?
Is that where they make the butter?
Is it?
Shout out Lucerne.
I think so.
Thanks for your question.
This is tricky.
I think it's important to, of course,
make the best choices
that are in alignment with your values.
And that's what Tanya's doing.
She's conscientious about her needs and her wants
and tries to make sure that her consumer choices
are in alignment with her values
and that's something to be celebrated.
And certainly, that's healthy modeling for your child,
because it's not about what you say,
it's about what you do, it's about your behavior.
But I also think this question has a lot to do
with controlling the controllables.
Understanding what you can control
and what you can't control,
and really having a healthy mindset
around how you calibrate all of that.
As a parent, you lead by example in action.
Again, you model this behavior for your kids.
But it's also important to not be a martyr,
especially if you're, if part of your interest
is in trying to inspire the next generation.
If you're suffering, then that doesn't become
an aspirational way to live your life.
And ultimately, that's gonna set you up
for your kid to just rebel,
saying I don't wanna live my life like that.
That doesn't look like any fun.
I wanna thrive.
And why was I deprived of all these things?
I'm gonna go out into the world and get them.
Like kids are always going to differentiate in that way.
And they're gonna wanna explore the opposite
of what they've been presented with.
So you have to be mindful about that a little bit.
And I think it's important to not overly in an unhealthy way
attach to how your child's moral compass will evolve.
And I say that as a parent of four,
and two teenagers right now,
like I've experienced a variety of permutations on this.
Everything from we love the way that you parented us
and we wanna model our own value system
based upon how we were raised to,
I don't want anything to do with this.
Keep that, get that vegan butter out of here.
And a lot of that just has to do
with how they come out of the womb.
You know what I mean?
But my point being that-
The ultimate blockchain.
You only have so much control over these things.
Yeah, exactly, the ultimate blockchain.
And I guess I would so say that I can appreciate
how it can at times feel dispiriting that perhaps you feel
like you're not making enough of a difference.
Like you make these small choices in your life,
but how much is this really moving the needle?
But I do think they hold symbolic power,
and they do model for other people in your orbit,
like what's important to you.
And it sends the message out
that this is something of value to you
and perhaps would be a value to other people.
But because there's so little we can control
in the kind of climate trajectory of our planet,
there are other ways that you can contribute,
through activism, or charity, or organizing,
because ultimately, the real change,
the big change is going to have to be systemic.
And that's gonna come through legislative
and regulatory changes,
not by a few isolated people sacrificing
all of their happiness and wellbeing
on the altar of like martyr sacrifice.
So I think it's important to reframe,
thinking about all of this to reframe
how you approach the mindset of your parents.
I assume your parents, your child's grandparents,
this idea that you're gonna change their minds, or that is-
I think it's in-laws.
Is it in-laws?
I'm sensing in-laws.
We don't know, we don't know what's going on in Lucerne.
No. (laughs)
Is it butter or in-laws?
I think it's in-laws.
You know, that's, you're setting
yourself up for a losing battle there.
Like these people are set in their ways.
It's very unlikely that you're gonna
get them to see things differently.
And you don't wanna leave yourself frustrated
and irreparably eroding a relationship
that is perhaps healthy in other ways.
I think that you have the opportunity
as your child gets older to contextualize
where your grandparents are coming from
and their life experience for your child as he gets older.
But in the meantime, all I have
is like my own kind of approach to all of this,
which is less about being in the business
of trying to change other people's minds
and more about just being a lighthouse.
Like if you could just be a beacon of positive energy
and positive change and living your life
in accordance with your values,
that's much more attractive,
and I also think magnetic and powerful
than bitching about how other people don't get it.
No doubt.
You have in-laws.
I have, I don't really.
Do they live in Lucerne?
I don't really.
You don't?
My wife is like Jason Bourne.
She comes from nowhere.
Oh really?
Interesting.
She's kind of, she's got a past.
So no, we're not really super, we do have,
I do have in-laws, but it's not like it's a close thing.
They're all in Australia.
And, but she has in-laws, I'll tell you that.
My wife has in-laws.
Right, so maybe she should be sitting here.
No.
You know, I think, and she's vegan,
but you know, it's different.
Like my parents aren't trying to yet feed,
he's obviously still nursing
and he's just getting into people food.
And so at some point he'll be spoiled
with ice cream and things that she won't
feed him in that exact way, I'm sure.
But that's not really on our plate.
I think this is interesting.
I think you made a really good point
in that all the people I know involved
in environmental activism from a consumer perspective
like the marine plastic pollution people,
like the real professionals, 5 Gyres,
and other organizations like that,
they will tell you the fight is upstream.
It's not about learning how to do everything with reusable.
It's not about like,
you can't erase all plastic from your life.
It's about stopping the production of future plastic.
Stopping those plastic plants.
Exactly like you were saying.
The fight, the changing of the world is upstream.
It's not necessarily in your daily life.
Now, on the other hand,
I can see how having a certain ethos
is a lifestyle in itself,
and it can actually be a confidence booster for you,
but you're flagging that it could also be repellent
for the child as the child grows.
The child is one years old.
Right,
kudos.
It's not a problem yet,
but like it's-
More will be revealed.
More will be revealed,
but I think those are all
interesting points and great points.
And the boomers are the boomers, right?
What are you gonna do?
Boomers gonna boom.
All right, let's go-
Shout out to boomers.
We love you.
Let's go to Christopher
from Boston.
Hi, my name is Christopher Hicks.
I am currently living in Boston, Massachusetts,
but I'm from Montana, but nonetheless big fan.
I'm an alcoholic and in recovery for quite a while,
but nonetheless catching the endurance bug
and finding endless inspiration from your story.
Right now, I'm currently training for The Rut 50K.
It's a sky running ultra endurance race in Big Sky, Montana.
So some friends and I are racing from around the country.
But my question is how to optimize
training for altitude races.
The race is actually ranging
between 7,000 up to just over 11,000 feet,
but living at sea level, how is it
that I could optimize my training here at sea level
in order to benefit my race coming up in September.
So anyways, any tips, tricks,
or just opinions that you have, that would be great.
All right, thank you.
Good question, Christopher.
Thanks for that.
There's a couple of things that you can do.
Some are expensive and some are free.
And I'm sure you've probably already heard of these.
I mean, you can of course purchase an altitude tent, right?
And sleep in that every night.
What is an altitude tent?
You haven't watched Alexi Pappas's movie?
No, no, I have not.
"Tracktown."
She, her whole bedroom is set up as an altitude tent
in this movie.
That's hilarious.
It's basically a pressurized tent
that you can put in your bedroom
and sleep in that approximates
what it's like to be at altitude by like, you know,
it's a reduction in the amount of oxygen, basically,
that acclimates you to altitude.
And then when you go out
and you go out of the tent and then you train,
you're obviously at sea level, so you get this boost,
so it's the back and the forth-
Like a decompression chamber kind of-
Sorta like that, yeah.
And I actually don't know how expensive those things are.
I just assume they're probably crazy expensive.
Hardcore endurance junkies swear by them.
Of course, you could take a weekend trip
to altitude and try to get some training in at 7,000 feet.
I don't know if that's possible,
especially during a pandemic.
And obviously that's something I'm sure you've,
that's occurred to you at some point.
So I don't know how helpful it is for me to mention that.
Another thing that some people have expressed
positive results from is wearing a training mask,
which is basically like, it kind of looks,
we're all wearing masks right now,
but it has like a gauge on it.
And it reduces the amount of airflow that you get.
I think it's just trainingmask.com, but-
Yeah, just running in your mask alone
could do some of that, right?
Basically,
but there is a difference between,
at true altitude, there's a lower oxygen
content of what you're breathing,
but you're not restricting air flow.
And there's something different
about restricting the airflow
while the oxygen ratio remains the same
that scientists have basically said, this is not,
this is a pretty ineffective way
of approximating altitude training.
There's an article on TrainRight about this.
I'll link it up in the show notes,
basically do altitude training masks
work for endurance athletes?
The essential conclusion is really not so much.
It might be good for mental training though,
to like feel what that feels like
to have a little bit of a reduced,
just to sort of prepare yourself for that experience.
But short of an altitude tent
or being able to train at altitude,
there are certain things that you can do in training.
You might wanna over-index a little bit more
than you would ordinarily
on interval training and hill training.
You're training for a 50K trail race,
it's probably a pretty zone two approach
that wouldn't require a lot of interval training
or like hill repeats, high intensity stuff.
But there are indications that weaving
that kind of work into your daily routine,
not your daily routine, your weekly routine,
can have some benefits in how
your body's going to process altitude.
I also would suggest arriving
at the event as early as possible,
as many days in advance as you possibly can.
What would you say would be-
It typically takes-
Ideal?
Well, seven days.
It really takes seven days to acclimate.
You may not be able to go a whole week ahead of time
to reap that benefit, but every day
I think is gonna be a little bit better if you can do that,
so that you can get used to it a little bit.
I also think you're gonna have to boost your hydration
and your caloric intake at altitude.
Your needs are gonna be different,
so over-indexing on hydration
and carbs is gonna be important.
And short of all of those things,
as you just go out and train on a daily basis,
anticipate that the suffering you're gonna experience
is gonna be different than what you're experiencing
in Boston, running around Massachusetts.
It's gonna be harder,
so just start to wrap your head mentally around that
and adjust your expectations accordingly.
Because nothing really compares
to training at altitude or racing at altitude.
So you gotta let go of whatever goals you have
around pace and time and focus on exertion.
Because that's really the only metric that's important
in trying to train at sea level and race at altitude.
Whatever your garment says about your pace is meaningless,
because it's just gonna be a lot harder
and you're gonna suffer.
Is your hydration 2X,
would you say?
That's a good question.
I think it's a personal thing.
I wouldn't say 2X off the bat.
I think it's something
that is gonna be different for everybody.
But just to be mindful and ahead of it
I think is gonna be important.
'Cause you get that lung burn
when you first run at altitude, right?
It's the worst.
Yeah.
And then you feel like you're
the only one who's feeling that,
like there must be something wrong with me
or I didn't train or this is gonna be terrible.
So I think just mentally preparing yourself for that
is something that would be wise to do.
And if he gets there seven days early,
how many runs should he get in?
Well, I think you should go,
if you get there seven days early,
go to the highest point that you can,
because there's probably a variety
in elevations once you get to the venue.
So the more time that you can spend
at the highest altitude possible
and doing your training leading up to the event
I think will be beneficial as well.
Fair enough, cool.
All right, we did it.
We done did it.
How are you doing?
How do you feel?
I feel good, man.
I feel, I feel good, man.
Do you feel like a podcaster?
I do, I feel like I could be NFT-ed right now.
That's how I feel.
You do?
Just NFT your body?
Just NFT me.
We could do a digital scan.
If it wasn't so environmentally-
3D print you.
If it wasn't so environmentally intensive,
I would just become an NFT.
Well, that is the future
that we're all looking at right now.
Especially if you read Kevin Roose's new book,
"Futureproof."
I can't wait to read
that book.
Yeah, you should read it.
And I might NFT one breath at some point.
That's really at odds
with your environmental activism, I don't know.
I can't see that happening.
No.
Unless you buy carbon offsets, right?
You can always balance it out.
The other thing about NFTs is,
there's all these hidden costs as well,
because you have to pay for the computing costs, I think,
so people who've sold stuff or bought stuff
then get these bills that they didn't expect
for the energy-
Oh, 'cause you need
to keep it going?
No.
I don't know exactly.
I read something about that.
I should just stop talking,
'cause I really don't know what I'm talking about.
Signing off.
Sign off.
We'll be back here in two weeks.
Until then, you can find Adam on Twitter
and on Instagram at Adam Skolnick.
I'm at Rich Roll.
Leave us a message if you'd like your question
fielded on a future edition of Roll On.
The number is 424-235-4626.
Check out the show notes on the episode page.
We'll link up tons of articles
on all the stuff that we talked about today.
You can find that at richroll.com.
Again, please subscribe to the show
on YouTube, Apple, Spotify, all the places.
And that's it.
Appreciate you guys, thanks for the love.
See you back here in a couple days
with another awesome episode.
I don't even know what we're putting up next,
but it's gonna be good, I think.
Will it be one of one?
It will be, it will be a one of one, yes.
What if you just made everything
that you did on the internet an NFT?
Like every tweet, every Facebook post, every Instagram.
Sounds exhausting.
Just NFT your entire experience.
Yes.
Think about that.
All right, we'll see you in two weeks, peace.
Plants.
Namaste.